mesdames et messieurs les ministres
madame la Défenseur des droits Mesdames
et Messieurs les parlementaires Mesdames
et Messieurs les élus monsieur le
Président de la CNCPH
Mesdames et Messieurs les présidents
d'associations mesdames et messieurs
c'est un honneur pour moi et un grand
privilège d'ouvrir aux côtés de
Jean-Christophe combe cette sixième
Conférence nationale du handicap la
précédente en 2020 avait eu lieu à la
date anniversaire de la loi du 11
février 2005 sur l'égalité des droits et
des chances
la CNH se vise à donner un cap et les
moyens d'atteindre cette égalité elle
identifie les obstacles qui freinent
encore l'accès aux droits fondamentaux
par tous les citoyens récemment le
Conseil de l'Europe nous a rappelé le
chemin qu'il reste à parcourir et ce
après l'ONU en 2021
notre objectif est donc de proposer un
changement de paradigme à la hauteur des
attentes des personnes en situation de
handicap et à la hauteur de leur choix
c'est à elle c'est à vous que je
m'adresse donc tout d'abord ainsi qu'aux
familles et aux représentants
d'associations et c'est avec humilité et
engagement que nous vous saluons
aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin d'une nouvelle feuille
de route pour fonder l'acte 2 de notre
politique en matière de handicap cette
feuille de route nous l'avons préparé
avec vous personne concernée association
en coordination avec les ministères les
parlementaires les associations des
collectivités territoriales AMF arf ADF
et France urbaine les entreprises et les
professionnels médico-sociaux ce sont
près de 500 personnes qui pendant 6 mois
ont participé au groupe de travail cette
méthode est exigeante mais elle est une
nécessité autant qu'un devoir la
co-construction et le meilleur moyen
d'identifier les problèmes pour trouver
les solutions adaptées aux besoins de
chacun alors merci à tous je remercie
particulièrement mes collègues ministres
et leurs équipes qui ont piloté
directement plusieurs groupes de travail
et c'est une première
qui témoigne tout simplement de cette
volonté de faire entrer les politiques
du handicap dans le droit commun je
remercie les hauts fonctionnaires au
handicap à l'inclusion les délégués
interministériels et le secrétariat
général du comité interministériel ou
handicap alors aujourd'hui le président
de la République va conclure cette CNH
en fixant le cadre pour les années à
venir et dès demain notre responsabilité
sera la mise en oeuvre effective de
cette ambition point par point
territoire par territoire en respectant
les engagements pluriannuels qui seront
pris et pour cela je souhaite associer
pleinement au suivi concret de cette
mise en application tous les acteurs
alors je ferme je forme le vœu pardon
que cette CNH vient interpeller tous les
Français
nous sommes à 16 mois de la cérémonie
d'ouverture des Jeux paralympiques de
Paris qui sera aussi un moment
exceptionnel pour transmettre autour du
handicap dans notre société
saisissons tous ces moments parce que
les droits des personnes en situation de
handicap ne seront pleinement respectées
que dans une société concernée je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]